Die kernfusion produziert eine unmenge an energie und wird deswegen auch als die neue primäre energiequelle
schlechthin gehandelt vielleicht schon bald die lösung aller energieprobleme
Weltweit ganz vorne im rennen mit dabei ist auch der fusionsreaktor
namen stalker marquez t40 bereits
Im vergangenen jahr hat er erstmals plasma erzeugt und wird so als heißer kandidat gehandelt
Mit dem bereits in naher zukunft die fusions kraft auch kommerziell genutzt werden könnte ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum thema poker marquez t40 herzlich willkommen bei kicks und science fiction
Ja und wir bei whatsapp mitmachen können dass er vater, am ende, des videos die kernfusion wäre ein riesenfortschritt
Um die energie problem mit dieser welt in angriff zu nehmen und so tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit daran
Im großen und ganzen ist die sonne das natürliche vorbild für das was während einer kernfusion passieren die atomkerne von
wasserstoff verschmelzen unter sehr hohem druck und bei sehr hohen temperaturen miteinander
im gegensatz zur kernspaltung bilden vereinfacht gesagt zwei leichter atome ein schweres die
Gesamtmasse des neuen atoms ist geringer als die der beiden einzeln das was fehlt
Das ist die entstandene energie das tolle der ganze prozess ist sehr viel ungefährlicher
Als die atom spaltung in kernkraftwerken wie wir sie heute
kennen denn selbst bei einem unfall
setzt ein fusionsreaktor nicht die unmengen an radioaktiver strahlung frei wie ankam kraftwerk und zudem
haben die radioaktiven stoffe die heber entstehen eine halbwertszeit von
jahrzehnten und eben nicht von jahrmillionen wie bei einem atomkraftwerk und genau diese gründe stacheln forschungsgruppen weltweit an
fusionsreaktoren immer
leistungsfähiger zu machen damit die von ihnen erzeugte fusions kraft
letztendlich auch kommerziell nutzbar ist denn auch wenn die vorteile der fusions kraft außer frage steht ist die erzeugung und vermarktung von fusionsenergie
weiterhin eine technische und wissenschaftliche
herausforderung in großbritannien fort beispielsweise das private unternehmen talker mark energy daran
Auf der webseite heißt es die fusion ist die ideale energiequelle weil sie sicher ist die brennstoffe
unerschöpflich sind und die reaktion kein kohlendioxid oder
langlebigen radioaktiven abfall produziert außerdem würde eine fusion sun lage nicht viel platz
Beanspruchen die talker markt für sie unsere aktion funktioniert etwas anders als wir es beispielsweise
vom
Stellarator aus greifswald kennen denn hier wird das magnetfeld zum teil von einem, im plasma
fließenden strom erzeugt das konzept beim töpfermarkt basiert also auf dem magnetischen einschluss ein plasma aus
Wasserstoff isotopen wird so auf etwa 100 bis 150
millionen grad erhitzt laut der offiziellen website von poker mack energy besteht die erste phase des prozesses darin
cluster temperaturen von 15 millionen grad celsius zu erreichen also
So heiß wie das zentrum der sonne noch in diesem jahr will talker mark energie dann
100 millionen grad erreichen dann erst dann würden die geladenen deuterium und tritium partikel die sich normalerweise
Abstoßen verschmelzen das ziel des unternehmens ist es. Im jahr 2025 mit dem sc 40 erste
elektrizität herzustellen ein wahnsinniger fortschritt und bis 2030 soll dann auch kommerziell nutzbaren fusionsenergie
Hergestellt werden das wäre der absolute hammer und viel schneller als bei anderen
Fusionsreaktoren bzw experimenten das konzept, des tokamak reaktors ist nicht neu es wurde schon
1952 von zwei britischen musikern in moskau entwickelt nur kurze zeit später wurden dann auch die ersten tokamak
experimente durchgeführt der der begriff zocker mag heißt übrigens übersetzt
So viel wie toro ideale kammer in magnetspulen wobei die silbe talk auf strom hindeutet und somit die besonderheit
Des zuckermarkt prinzips hervorhebt den stromfluss, im plassmann
Im frühling 2017 wurde talker mag in betrieb genommen und das erste plasma konnte erzeugt werden dazu. Hieß es in der pressemitteilung
Heute ist ein wichtiger tag für die entwicklung von fusions energien großbritannien und der welt wie es sie 40 ist eine maschine die fusions
temperaturen 100 millionen grad in kompakten
Kostengünstigen reaktoren zeigt damit kann uns kraft in jahren nicht in jahrzehnten erreicht werden das wäre wirklich
Eine absolute revolution wenn er als erstes neues zum thema kernfusion und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollen denn endet hier meine telefonnummer
prozent dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vom klick zum mitmachen mir zum beispiel themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und und in der begrüßungs nachricht unbedingt sorgfältig lesen da gibt es ein kleines goodie da haben sich schon viele
darüber gefreut also einfach hier klicken und
natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
kernfusion vor dem durchbruch
ansonsten bislang
bleibt dran